[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  at the 2018 ACM Awards Carrie Underwood  made a triumphant return to the stage  only months after a bad fall sent her to  the hospital  ét caught up with host Reba McEntire  backstage after the show Carrie I mean  that I mean talk about like blowing away  all these incredible performances but  the reaction of the crowd and what did  you think when you saw her up there  performing I'm very proud of Carrie  she's going through a lot and I am proud  that she's back on the stage again she's  a tremendous vocalist incredible yeah  got legs to die for but she's an  incredible vocalist here isn't she yeah  yeah those gams are pretty good yeah and  it's so proud of her the reaction of the  crowd what did you think when you saw  that oh I did I wasn't surprised at all  I wasn't shocked you know I knew  everybody was gonna be very grateful  that she's back and and she's doing well  she's healthy beautiful beautiful we  love her  [Music]  [Applause]